bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
reportage et d'expertise sur Public
Sénat 90 minutes de séquences un premier
débat actu et un autre plus prospectif
consacré aux mutations de nos sociétés
voici le sommaire de ce 29 septembre 10
solutions dissolution c'est le mot qui
tourne en boucle dans tous les états
majors politiques depuis hier soir
depuis qu'il a été prononcé par Emmanuel
Macron lors de ce dîner destiné à caler
le calendrier de la réforme des
retraites l'exécutif laisse trois mois
au partenaires sociaux pour discuter
mais comme l'a dit le président de la
République si c'est la Surly et en cas
de motion de censure tout le monde
retournera en campagne électorale on
débattra de cette menace et du climat
social de la rentrée et puis dans 45
minutes je vous propose un gros plan sur
les inondations au Pakistan la pire
catastrophe humanitaire selon le
secrétaire général des Nations Unies
dans le monde mais je n'ai jamais vu de
carnage climatique de cette ampleur
sommes-nous entrer dans l'air des mégas
catastrophes combien de réfugiés
climatiques vont influer à nos portes
dans les prochaines années pourquoi les
pays pauvres parlent-ils de double peine
et d'injustice climatique réponse tout à
l'heure mais d'abord donc cette journée
de mobilisation pour les salaires et les
retraites alors que la première ministre
a lancé ce matin un nouveau cycle de
négociation Jérémy Hansmann
donner plus de temps à la réforme des
retraites après un dîner à l'Élysée avec
plusieurs ministres et responsables de
la majorité Emmanuel Macron temporise et
fait le choix du dialogue en lançant ce
jeudi un nouveau cycle de concertation
avec les partenaires sociaux et les
groupes politiques une méthode moins
brutale mais une fermeté affichée sur le
contenu de la réforme
identique selon l'exécutif à celui
annoncé pendant la campagne
présidentielle avec un recul de l'âge de
départ à 65 ans en 2031 un montant
minimal de pension relevé à 1100 euros
une prise en compte de la pénibilité et
la fin des régimes spéciaux le président
de la République s'est engagé sur deux
aspects à la fois un cadre général avec
l'augmentation progressive de l'âge et
l'équilibre du système mais aussi une
mise en application de la loi partir de
l'été 2023 notre objectif la première
ministre l'a dit très clairement c'est
d'ouvrir cette série de concertation
avant Noël d'en faire le bilan et
d'avoir un texte qui puisse être le plus
partagé possible et que ce texte soit
adopté avant la fin de l'hiver un projet
de loi à part entière et donc privilégié
plutôt qu'un amendement au projet de loi
de finance de la sécurité sociale dès le
mois d'octobre mais les discussions
s'annoncentues avec les syndicats
mobilisés ce jeudi et opposer à un recul
de l'âge légal de départ à la retraite
si le gouvernement est pas capable
d'entendre et d'entendre et surtout de
prendre en compte ce qui se dit de
l'autre côté de la table de la part de
tous les syndicats qui disent il y a
d'autres solutions que de travailler
plus longtemps c'est un dialogue de
sourd et ceux qui sont source et ceux
qui sont au gouvernement des tensions à
venir également avec le Parlement
d'ailleurs Emmanuel Macron n'exclut pas
de dissoudre l'Assemblée nationale en
cas de vote d'une motion de censure par
les oppositions voilà beaucoup de leçons
à tirer de ce dîner hier soir qui lance
donc un rang de négociation de
concertation autour de la réforme des
retraites et pour en débattre
j'accueilleina bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes constitutionnaliste et maître de
conférence en droit public Sylvain
boulot que bonsoir et bienvenue
historien spécialiste du communisme des
mouvements anarchistes et de l'extrême
gauche et vous publiez auteur du livre
le peuple du drapeau noir une histoire
des anarchistes et aux éditions Atland
j'accueille également Raphaël Legendre
pardon bonsoir Raphaël bienvenue
journaliste à l'opinion et Laetitia
cruppa éditoris politique bonsoir
Laetitia peut-être pour commencer un mot
de la mobilisation de cette journée pour
les salaires et les retraites à l'appel
des syndicats CGT FSU et Solidaires il y
a eu un peu plus de 200 rassemblements
en France on va voir s'afficher les les
chiffres de mobilisation qui sont
relativement faibles à Marseille entre
4300 et 30000 manifestants bon comme
toujours il y a des écarts assez
importants Perpignan quand je vous
laisse découvrir c'est ces chiffres
Sylvain boulouc c'est une petite
mobilisation mais ça naugure pas de la
suite enfin c'est impossible de dire
aujourd'hui ce qui peut se passer dans
les prochaines semaines
de toute manière il y avait pas tous les
partenaires enfin toutes les
organisations syndicales qui appelaient
à la manifestation puisque il y avait
que deux voire trois des principales
organisations qui appelaient
petite mobilisation aussi parce que elle
a été lancé relativement tardivement et
pour l'instant on était un peu enfin les
partenaires sociaux ou tous les cas les
organisations syndicales étaient plutôt
dans les spectative et donc par
conséquent les salariés aussi devaient
attendre si tenter qu'il soit hostile
aux réformes qu'ils se profile à
l'horizon c'est il faut il faut il faut
toujours résister très prudent dans une
séquence comme celle-là il y a des
mouvements sociaux il faut toujours
rester très prudent parce que
allumette peut mettre le feu à la plaine
ou il peut ne rien se passer du tout là
on ne sait absolument pas comment
l'opinion peut réagir ou ne pas réagir
au projet de réforme puisque comment
seulement à avoir les premiers les
premières étapes du projet de réforme
comme elles sont tombées hier soir et
entre hier soir et ce matin ça faisait
pas beaucoup pour les organisations
syndicales pour remobiliser en sachant
que la majeure partie d'entre elles
n'appelait pas mobilisée alors qu'elles
sont elles se sont toutes déclarées au
style au projet au premier projet de
réforme tel qu'il pouvait exister avec
une retraite repoussée à 65 ans
effectivement alors le donc il y a cette
mobilisation et puis l'info de la
journée quand même sur ce dossier des
retraites je le disais en titre on l'a
vu avec le sujet de Jérémy hansman c'est
c'est ce calendrier donc qui laisse la
place à trois mois de de négociation un
challenge busina le on peut dire que le
Président de la République a écouté les
mises en garde d'un François Bayrou ou
de il y a le bon sujet la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale en effet et puis
il est un petit peu plus fidèle quand
même à ce qu'il avait promis
c'est-à-dire que on devait avoir un
président de la nouvelle méthode et
cette nouvelle méthode devait être celle
de la concertation donc c'est vrai que
passer un amendement dans un projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale où vous savez que le Parlement
en a que 50 jours pour discuter avec un
49-3 dans un amendement ça a donné quand
même un petit peu l'impression de voilà
de d'être déjà dans l'urgence et en plus
dans le fait de court-circuiter un petit
peu le Parlement on lui a reproché cette
verticalité dans le premier quinquennat
et il avait dit justement qu'il allait
changer de méthode parlementaire
également donc je pense que c'est
peut-être une manière de voilà de
respecter un petit peu mieux les droits
du Parlement ce qui était notamment
l'appel de François Bayrou et il faut
savoir qu'il est justement un peu tendu
entre les deux ailes de sa majorité
puisque il a une majorité très composite
ce président à l'Assemblée nationale et
donc du coup même pour agiter un
éventuel 49-3 par la suite il faut qu'il
soit sûr que sa majorité soit bien
derrière lui parce que ça peut parfois
se jouir à une à deux voies près donc le
temps de la concertation c'est une
manière aussi de dire qu'il a entendu
dans ces rangs pour pour resserrer
autour de lui c'est pas garanti ensuite
que ces deux mois et demi suffisent à
trouver un consensus parfait on est bien
d'accord que en termes de sociologie des
organisations syndicales qui s'agissent
des organisations syndicales ou des
partis politiques personne n'est
appropriée en accord sur ce que doit
être cette réforme des retraites et si
elle est celle qu'on nous a promis
c'est-à-dire l'allongement à 65 ans
personne n'en veut non plus donc voilà
c'est juste une manière de voilà
d'assouplir la méthode sans forcément à
mon avis changer le résultat Gilles
Legendre le le
je ne suis pas député
et alors journalier j'ai commencé par
écorcher votre famille et ensuite on
s'est pas mal comme début d'émission
excusez-moi Raphaël je suis vraiment
désolé je voulais quand même appuyer sur
ce qu'est la volonté des manettes Macron
qui est qui dit grosso modo je suis là
pour réformer et sans et sans trop
perdre de temps il y a quand même aussi
ça dans le message d'hier soir et dans
le calendrier qui a été choisi une
séquence très politique et assez ambiguë
le Emmanuel Macron il hésite depuis la
rentrée sur la méthode à tenir une
semaine on a le Conseil national de la
refondation qui est là pour la
discussion pour la concertation les
participants c'était le 8 septembre ont
bien noté la drague qui a fait le chef
de l'État envers Laurent Berger qui est
quand même l'acteur pivot de cette de
cette réforme et puis patatras la
semaine suivante grande conférence de
presse avec 200 journalistes et là il
indique bravage écoutez on pourra très
bien passer par un amendement dans le
PLFSS c'est un bras d'honneur à tous les
partenaires sociaux donc on savait pas
trop sur quel pied danser ces dernières
semaines jusqu'à la sortie de François
Bay qui est lui-même le secrétaire
général le dirigeant du Conseil national
de la refondation qui surtout pour
garder son poste a fait cette sortie en
disant il va falloir quand même qu'on
puisse concerter sinon le CNR était mort
de facto et on est un peu vu un peu
moins vu François il se trouve que hier
soir et ben c'est François Bayrou qui
bien arrivé une demi-heure en retard au
dîner et ressorti gagnant c'est un geste
envers François Bayrou et le modem du
président de la République je ne suis
pas sûr que la concertation soit ce
qu'il aurait préféré en tout cas en
terme d'efficacité c'est pas vraiment ce
qu'il y a de ce qui est certain c'est ce
qu'il y a pas ça n'est pas ce qu'il y a
de plus rapide pardon parce que les
positions vous l'avez rappelé des uns et
des autres elles sont connues et archi
connues de tous on a négocié pendant des
milliers d'heures des milliers de
exactement sur le sur la même forme
comme exactement sur la même réforme
mais enfin 80%, ce recoupe on enlève la
réforme à point la réforme systémique
était le la grande cathédrale de
Jean-Paul de ça c'est fini enfin tout le
reste les positions des uns et des
autres des syndicats du patronat et du
gouvernement sont totalement connus donc
on peut relancer trois mois de
discussion on va perdre 3 mois dans la
mise en application ce sera 2 milliards
et au budgétaire de deux mois on n'est
plus à ça près dans le quoi qu'il en
coûte mais et bien le jeu politique va
se mettre en place maintenant reste à
voir la réaction des syndicats la CFDT a
demandé d'une concertation
loyale et transparence transparente
pardon la CGT n'a pas encore
officiellement annoncé qu'elle y
participait FO idem donc on verra la
semaine prochaine comment ça va voir
comment ça se passe s'il veut un boulouc
tiens on parle de quoi de c'est une
concertation sont des négociations
est-ce que les mots ont aussi un sens
là on est quand même devant un paradoxe
c'est-à-dire que les objectifs sont
fixés ce sera de toute manière le projet
de réforme c'est celui-là et pas un
autre
les éléments qui permet qui aurait
permis peut-être de négocier c'était
cette cette ancienne réforme qui a été
enterrée de delvois par point dans
laquelle la cfdta était plutôt favorable
était engagée ce qui permettait de
justement d'avoir une négociation avec
les partenaires sociaux qu'est-ce que tu
donnes qu'est-ce que je prends c'est une
fausse négociation qui s'ouvre en fait
là si vous dites voilà de toute manière
ce sera la retraite à 65 ans avec une
probabilité il faut m'expliquer ce qui
reste comme comme aspect de négociation
c'est c'est à peu près enfin il y a plus
de négociation c'est on va arriver à ça
voilà alors est-ce que est-ce qu'ils ont
prévu dans la négociation des des
certains points il y a différents points
il y a les cahiers longs il y a la
pénibilité
très important des régimes spéciaux
retraite le minimum retraite aussi donc
il y a du gramme ou non pour reprendre
la la phrase de Monsieur Bergeron et oui
mais justement là pour l'instant voilà
voilà le projet de réforme qu'est-ce qui
reste à négocier là c'est on est dans le
flou le plus artistique et
central dans dans ce qui était proposé
pour par les par les par deux des
acteurs qui auraient permis puisqu'en
plus comprennent la CMDT ou une SAS
c'est quand même une partie de
l'électorat maître macroniste qui qui
est derrière et là pour l'instant je
sais après on va voir ce que les
négociations c'est ce que donneront les
négociations mais pour l'instant ça
laisse pour le mois perplexe parce que
la négociation c'est pour ça que je je
sais pas une négociation ce sont des
choses très séparées la discussion dans
le dialogue social la concertation c'est
on vous écoute et puis on verra ce qu'on
garde quand tu négociation c'est
vraiment la co-construction d'un texte
alors on va écouter ce qu'on pense le
président du Medef Geoffroy de Bézieux
c'était sur France Info ce matin
il me semble que sur une réforme aussi
importante qui concerne presque tous les
Français peut-être à part ceux qui sont
déjà à la retraite
c'était difficile de pas faire une
concentration maintenant on connaît
effectivement vous l'avez dit les
positions les grandes positions des uns
et des autres on a fait deux ans de
concertation il y a 3 ans sur une autre
réforme sur une autre réforme c'est vrai
mais dont certains paramètres sont déjà
enfin été déjà sur la table donc nous on
ira évidemment à se concertation on
répondra enfin d'abord on examinera ce
qui est proposé puisque vous le dites on
ne connaît pas tous les détails et puis
on aura des propositions à faire bien
sûr
bon vous êtes pas spécialiste de
l'histoire syndicale ou des négociations
mais de votre regard de
constitutionnalisme moi j'ai
l'impression d'une espèce de jeu de rôle
là comment vous le comment vous
l'analysez alors à la fois il y a moi je
trouve c'est tout le paradoxe de cette
nouvelle méthode c'est à dire qu'en fait
on nous a promis que les choses allaient
être nouvelles sans qu'on sache vraiment
comment on allait incarner cette
nouveauté et là je crois qu'on est
vraiment dans le cœur de ce problème là
c'est à dire que déjà pour la
concertation il me semble qu'il faut
qu'on se concerte sur quelque chose dont
on connaît plus ou moins l'objectif et
le fond et c'est vrai que la feuille de
route quand même très générale générique
qu'on a on n'a pas vraiment le fond de
la discussion donc j'ai l'impression
qu'en fait cette nouvelle méthode c'est
c'est un peu ça fait partie du discours
macronie c'est-à-dire cette manière
d'incarner par les mots avec la start-up
nation et ce qu'on avait eu en 2017 là
maintenant on est dans dans l'idée
d'être dans la concertation la
co-construction on a employé tout un
nouveau vocabulaire
alors voilà c'est que dans les actes en
fait déjà au niveau législatif il faut
savoir que la co-construction ça
n'existe pas c'est soit un référendum de
ratification c'est à dire une fois le
projet déjà prêt soit finalement une
consultation auparavant mais c'est
toujours le Parlement qui récupère le
pouvoir du vote donc il y a il y a pas
vraiment de co-construction possible en
termes législatif donc déjà ça je pense
que c'est une première chose qu'il faut
dire pour le conseil de la refondation
pour toutes les négociations en général
et ensuite cette co-construction est-ce
qu'on va vraiment lui permettre
d'aboutir c'est à dire sur quel point on
va pouvoir discuter jusqu'où euh et
c'est pour ça que quand on nous parlait
d'un amendement au même au projet de loi
rectificatif donc dont on nous parle
quand même ces derniers temps en janvier
février voilà on peut pas garder une
discussion restreinte sur ces points là
donc à voir sur cette géométrie variable
de la nouvelle méthode alors dans ce
dîner à l'Elysée donc il y a eu ce thème
de semaine parlé le calendrier le
renoncement au passage en force mais
laetitia est aussi donc un mot c'était
mon premier titre qui est ressorti et
c'était pas un hasard le mot dissolution
ah non ce n'est pas du tout au hasard
quand vous parlez de mise en scène je
pense que vous avez totalement raison
Thomas c'est une orchestration ça
s'appelle de la communication et c'est
fait a priori de façon plutôt réussie
pourquoi parce que finalement l'exécutif
l'objectif de l'exécutif c'est de
retourner la menace de la dissolution
qui était brandie rappelez-vous par
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui visait Matignon
ils vont la retourner comme étant une
arme de leur côté je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi mais d'abord on va revenir sur
cette opération de communication donc
orchestrée par l'Elysée avec ce mot
dissolution il faut faire sortir parce
que c'est un dîner qui est à huis clos
donc il n'y a pas de journaliste a
priori il faut faire sortir ce mot
dissolution ça s'appelle de la
communication indirecte via la méthode
de la fuite très bien maîtrisée par
Emmanuel Macron et réussi parce que elle
à la fois notre journaliste un
journaliste averti Jérémy bien sûr l'a
dit dans son sujet tous les journalistes
de France l'ont dit ce matin comme par
exemple j'en ai pris un autre confrère
Guillaume Daret sur France 2 On ne
reculera pas ce qui se joue c'est
l'autorité de votre serviteur à dire
Emmanuel Macron selon les mots rapportés
par plusieurs convives Emmanuel Macron
qui pour la première fois aussi
hostensiblement laisse planer
l'hypothèse d'une dissolution en cas de
vote d'une motion de censure à
l'Assemblée nationale alors l'autorité
de votre serviteur est en jeu ça c'est
l'élément de langage qui accompagne
l'hypothèse de la dissolution mais alors
cette fois dans la dans l'opération
comme l'Elysée est allé un peu plus loin
puisque c'est pas contenté de la presse
les lieutenants au front alors les
lieutenants de la deuxième ligne et de
la première ligne on va commencer par la
deuxième ligne stanisasquerini par
exemple
ministre des comptes publics qui
n'étaient pas au dîner mais qui est un
proche d'Emmanuel Macron écoutez-le
c'était sur cnews ce matin
il amène évoqué ce soi-disant vous allez
me le confirmer la dissolution de
l'Assemblée nationale moi
d'abord c'est pas une phrase que j'ai
entendu je n'étais pas au dîner
c'est pas faux mais de commenter des
propos qui sont pas des propos officiels
la réalité c'est que nous nous voulons
avancer bon il est commente pas mais il
dit pas non plus hein que ils ne vont
pas le faire pourquoi parce qu'il ne
veut simplement pas griller la politesse
à la première ligne le lieutenant de la
première ligne c'est Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail qui sera en charge
de porter cette réforme des retraites
lui il est allé carrément Franco sur LCI
je n'ai pas pour habitude de rapporter
les propos du président de la République
mais ce que je peux vous assurer c'est
que le Président de la République
considère qu'il a été élu une évidence
qu'il dispose d'une majorité majorité
relative mais une majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale et que si à un moment ou à
notre la totalité des oppositions se
coaliser alors que il n'y a rien de
commun entre les différents groupes
d'opposition qu'il n'y a que des
d'accord entre eux parfois même au sein
de chacun des groupes de position si
toutes les oppositions squalisées pour
adopter une notion de censure et faire
tomber le gouvernement et s'en remettrai
aux Français et les Français
trancheraient alors cette éventualité de
dissolution avec été évoqué du bout des
lèvres par Emmanuel Macron à la fin de
l'été maintenant on y est carrément et
puis finalement ils veulent donner la
preuve que notre
serviteur à tous Emmanuel ah le courage
politique il faut quand même garder un
peu les éléments de langage si on veut
décrypter la communication de l'exécutif
et c'est surtout une menace aussi Thomas
pour les députés qui comme par exemple
les députés LR n'ont pas du tout envie
de remettre leur siège en jeu si de
nouvelles élections devaient avoir lieu
Raphaël Legendre Savinsky cette phrase
Emmanuel Macron effectivement je ne veux
pas lâcher en ligne si ça bloque tout le
monde retournera en campagne s'il y a
motion de censure je il y aura la
dissolution sadisky la menace bon cette
idée de dissolution d'abord elle circule
depuis les législatives en réalité on
rappelle que Emmanuel mic Macron ne
dispose plus que d'une majorité relative
à l'Assemblée nationale ce qui complique
absolument tous les passages des projets
de loi c'est effectivement le moyen
aussi de renverser les attaques des des
oppositions c'est aussi une manière de
rentrer dans le dialogue social ce qu'il
fait assez régulièrement un peu avec un
flingue sur la tombe pour ceux qui qui
participent là aussi menacé si les
discussions n'avançaient pas dans la
concertation d'éventuellement passer
quand même une fine par un amendement
dans le projet de loi de financement de
la Sécu donc de balayer aussi toute la
concertation ça réveille un peu les
troupes motion de censure a quand même
très peu de chance de passer à
l'Assemblée nationale dans la mesure où
comme vous l'avez rappelé les députés
les quelques députés LR qui restent et
qui ont vraiment mouillé la chemise sur
le terrain pour être élu non absolument
pas envie d'y retourner et puis
accessoire
le fond de la réforme pardon le fond de
la réforme des retraites des retraites
c'est quand même assez conforme à ce que
à ce que souhaite le parti LR les
accessoirement même si on cherche de
plus en plus la colonne vertébrale chez
les LR depuis quelques temps il sera
difficile pour eux de ne pas la voter
effectivement on ne voit pas tout
simplement
si vous voulez vous poser la question
Anne Charlène qu'il y a une
contradiction entre cette nouvelle
méthode et la nature même de notre
régime présidentiel finalement parce que
Emmanuel Macron fait comme si on était
dans un régime parlementaire avec des
coalitions où il fallait discuter et
qu'il y avait des compromis à obtenir et
finalement tout cela et c'est pour ça
que je vous rejoins Thomas c'est de la
mise en scène c'est pas vrai c'est lui
qui décide même quand on a une majorité
relative alors sur la dissolution oui
c'est un pouvoir propre et de toute
façon vous avez raison l'ADN du régime
de la Cinquième République c'est le on
dit que c'est la clé de voûte des
pouvoirs notamment parce que c'est lui
qui pouvait actionner tous les pouvoirs
les uns avec les autres et je dirais
même que d'ailleurs ce combo motion de
censure dissolution on a l'impression
qu'on le découvre aujourd'hui mais c'est
pas du tout inédit on a déjà eu
exactement le même cas en 1962 avec le
général de Gaulle qui est tellement
énervé qu'on lui renverse son
gouvernement alors qu'on voulait s'en
prendre à lui parce qu'il faut savoir
que le président est un grand
irresponsable au niveau politique et
donc on renverse Pompidou dans les 48
heures il dit sous l'Assemblée nationale
et le prétexte c'est au moins c'est le
peuple qui tranchera alors le résultat a
été totalement dans sa faveur puisque
finalement il y a eu un
raz-de-maréguliste enfin un peu plus
relatif que ce qu'il a eu en 68 mais oui
cette présidentialisation elle existe
parce que en réalité dans le discours le
président peut toujours ramener à lui le
jeu politique il reste que la
dissolution c'est quand même une arme à
une arme à double tranchant on a tous un
petit peu en tête cette espèce de
Mistigri de la de la dissolution de 97
qui avait été très mal pensé par Jacques
Chirac et donc la dissolution c'est une
question timing il faut trouver le bon
moment c'est pour ça que d'ailleurs en
Grande-Bretagne normalement c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas
constitutionnalisé il faut que le
premier ministre sent le moment et en
France c'est un petit peu pareil est-ce
que là malgré le côté un petit peu je
montre les muscles du président qui
consiste à dire et bien si vous me
renversez c'est moi qui vous renverse
est-ce que c'est lui qui est surdit
gagné à voir c'est intéressant si ma
boulot parce qu'il y a une espèce de
double menace dans les propos qui voilà
effectivement été fait fuité du
Président hier il y a appelle le côté
émotion de censure attention il y aura
des solutions donc là c'est vers les
députés et puis il y a cette petite
phrase si c'est la chiotique tout le
monde retournera en campagne et là quand
on dit la champlit forcément ça fait
référence à la mobilisation populaire à
la rue De Gaulle bon bref et donc là
c'est plutôt au syndicat avec la menace
l'adresse comment vous le voulez
souligner et en même temps c'est un clin
d'œil et un appel appuyé à une partie de
la droite qui assure qui veut surtout
pas d'achainer dans la rue pour
reprendre l'héritage gaulliste donc on
se retrouve effectivement avec un parti
du présidentiel qui veut être le parti
de l'ordre partie de l'ordre qui impose
ses réformes en disant c'est c'est moi
ou le chaos on peut en prendre une autre
une autre métaphore et donc du coup
alors là après ça pose le problème de
quel concertation ou quel dialogue
social puisque si vous dites vous avez
pas le droit de manifester parce que ça
détacher un lit vous avez pas le droit
de vous opposer parce que c'est sinon je
dis sous ça laisse perplexe sur la
réalité des de dénégociations possibles
c'est est-ce qu'il y a une négociation
ou est-ce que on est dans un chantage à
double chantage
il y en a pas vraiment à moins d'arriver
au Parlement à travailler ensemble et
encore une fois ils nous ont pas montré
sur les temps
mais s'il y a dissolution une nouvelle
élections législatives peut-être un
parti qui va en profiter c'est le parti
du rassemblement national en effet
peut-être moins les LFI et la coalition
de la news
c'est très difficile d'ailleurs de
dissoudre avec effet gagnant parce que
vous vous ne pouvez absolument pas
imaginer quels seront les effets des
urnes et en plus je trouve ça assez
paradoxal de le lancer en période de
crise sociale justement parce que c'est
un espèce de combo de la dissolution de
62 et des élections de 68 et de la
dissolution de 68 justement mais encore
une fois c'est juste pour dire aux
Français c'est c'est moi et vous
finalement c'est c'est il s'adresse
Emmanuel Macron directement en français
les syndicats là encore une fois ils
sont instrumentalisés dans cette mise en
scène de négociation il n'y a pas de
négociation en fait il s'adresse même
directement à son électorat en France
son socle électoral qui est quand même
majoritairement fait de retraités qui
sont tout à fait favorables à la réforme
de retraite puisque ils sont plus
concernés par cette réforme des
retraites donc il sait qu'il a un sac
électoral d'environ 25 à 30% qui lui
garantit à peu près
des résultats positifs à chaque élection
après après ça peut être malgré tout des
parties risquées parce que bah vous avez
quand même plus de 50% des gens qui vont
pas voter si jamais ce jour-là ils
décident d'aller voter ça peut être une
drôle de surprise comme ça peut ne pas
l'être puisqu'ils peuvent ne plus jamais
aller voter aussi alors une réaction à
cette à cette menace celle de d'Olivier
fort pour le Parti socialiste c'était
sur Twitter le prix en république menace
de dissolution si l'assemblée n'approuve
pas la retraite à 65 ans il espère que
nos convictions passeront derrière nos
mandats nous battrons pour la justice ne
céderont pas intimidation
puériles et puis vous parliez
Raphaël tout à l'heure de finalement de
François Bayrou et du fait qu'il a
peut-être obtenu gain de cause lors de
ces dîners hier soir je vous propose une
autre citation elle nous vient en fait
elle a été sans doute propose qui ont
été rapportés par le journaliste notre
confrère Bruno jeudi voilà ce que
Emmanuel Macron aurait prononcé hier
lors de ce dîner certains ont essayé de
devenir président sans jamais y parvenir
moi je suis président sur la base d'un
projet ça c'est clairement une pique
François Bayrou quand même non mais
c'est
il a fait son show hier il a laissé
parler tout le monde tout le monde il y
a eu des petites piques pour les uns et
les autres c'est à dire que le premier à
qui il a donné la parole sur qu'elle
devrait être la méthode pour faire
passer cette réforme de retraite cet été
Edouard Philippe à qui il avait bien
sonné d'accord j'ai coupé l'herbe sous
le pied c'est
nos confrères du monde qui ont publié
aujourd'hui un papier très bien informé
voilà sur sur sur ce qui s'est passé
Édouard Philippe
ont rigolé sous cap mais après avoir
laissé parler l'ensemble des
participants il leur a demandé de poser
les stylos de poser les portables et
leur écouter il y en a un qui a pris son
risque ici c'est moi tout cela est
inscrit dans mon projet présidentiel
donc maintenant on y va voilà on passe
par la concertation soit mais il faut y
aller elle sera appliquée au mois de
juillet 2023 cette loi alors c'est
intéressant parce que vous l'avez dit il
y a l'autorité de votre serviteur il y a
cette question d'autorité de légitimité
même du président qui sont en jeu et
c'est aussi ce que ces opposants
remettent régulièrement en cause en
question nouvel exemple c'était Fabien
Roussel ce matin sur RTL
le président de la République devrait se
souvenir qu'au premier tour d'élection
présidentielle il a échappé de justesse
quand même
il a fait un très mauvais score et que
s'il a été élu au second tour c'est
parce qu'une majorité de Français ne
voulait pas de l'extrême droite au
pouvoir alors c'est aussi si Mabrouk a
un argument qu'on a entendu plusieurs
fois ces derniers jours dans la bouche
de Philippe Martinez par exemple le
secrétaire général de la de la CGT
comment vous l'analyse parce que
Emmanuel Macron bon il a quand même été
élu aussi pour faire la réforme des
retraites
si on fait la somme des élections et les
moins bien élue moins bien élu pardon
qu'en 2017 et
le deuxième tour et encore une fois un
rejet de d'abord un rejet de du
rassemblement national avant d'être une
adhésion à son projet donc il est élu
mais il est élu par rejet plus que par
adhésion globale la première fois il
était plutôt comme un élu sur une
adhésion là il est plutôt élu sur un
rejet massif enfin moins massif que la
première fois mais un rejet du il est
quand même au premier tour c'est le
nombre de voix progresse d'ailleurs qui
fait quand même mieux au premier tour
même si effectivement le second temps
est un peu moins et il est quand même
élu sur un projet ça a été dire que s'il
y a une s'il y a peut-être une seule une
seule proposition que les électeurs
retenus c'est celle de la réforme des
retraites justement avec des 65 ans mère
de toute la réforme c'est ce qu'on avait
dit à l'époque et le curseur son mandat
sera jugé à l'aune de cette réforme des
retraits il arrive à t-il ou pas s'il
cochera la case réformateur si cette
réforme passe beaucoup plus que
l'assurance chômage par exemple qui
arrive là et qui est beaucoup moins
marqueur dans l'opinion publique c'est
vraiment la réforme a réussi pour lui en
ce débutant avec un taux d'abstention
très élevé
et des députés qui sont plus mal élus
les uns que les autres donc là il y a
des questions enfin c'est il peut
déboucher sur un mouvement social
d'ampleur ou pas c'est qu'on a quand
même toute une partie de l'opinion qui
qui clairement disent je n'en ai plus
rien à faire du système électoral ça ne
me correspond plus ça veut pas dire que
c'est parti de l'opinion soit prête à
enfin ne soit pas prête à manifester ou
à marquer son opposition avec un projet
de réforme parce que peut considérer que
c'est un coup de plus sur sur la tête
un peu ce qui est un peu senti le
rassemblement national depuis depuis
quelques depuis quelques semaines il y a
un autre mot dont on parlera dans un
instant j'aimerais vous entendre les uns
et d'autres c'est le mot lassitude parce
que j'ai l'impression que le chef de
l'État il compte un peu sur une forme de
lassitude des Français mais je voudrais
être bouclée la question de l'autorité
et de la légitimité avec vous à Anne
Charlène parce que peut-être que
finalement la légitimité présidentielle
par
paradoxalement ce sont les législatives
qui les ont plus entamé puisque il
réussit pas contrairement à certains
beaucoup de ses prédécesseurs à obtenir
une majorité absolue alors après oui
bien sûr le terme légitimité
présidentielle pour moi c'est celui de
la légalité c'est-à-dire qu'à partir du
moment où vous êtes issu d'un processus
sélectif vous êtes élu pour la ligne
mais il y a quelque chose qui est qui
faut rappeler c'est que la lune de miel
ne jure jamais très longtemps avec le
peuple qui pourtant vous a élu la France
et historiquement est un des peuples les
plus volatiles en termes de voilà de de
stabilité de l'opinion de de soutien
derrière ses élites et donc quand bien
même on a entendu parler des recettes il
y a les mots et il y a les choses et
donc quand cette réforme est en passe de
passer on est en janvier février mars
toute une période un peu compliquée
vient de se passer avec la guerre en
Ukraine le prix de l'énergie le pouvoir
d'achat etc et donc il se peut même que
ceux qui l'ont soutenu en mars dernier
ne soutiennent pas en mars prochain
c'est vraiment ça à mon avis le le
facteur clé bien plus que de savoir s'il
est électorat a été réellement mobilisé
derrière lui c'est que quand bien même
il aurait été mobilisé il peut tout à
fait sa démobilisé ensuite donc pour moi
je crois que
le pari cette réforme des retraites
c'est en effet le pari de l'engagement
c'est-à-dire à partir du moment où ça
faisait partie de son programme
présidentiel il a été élu pour le faire
et il va aller au bout mais encore une
fois on a vu avec les gilets jaunes on
peut venir d'être élu avoir l'impression
d'être encore porté par ce souffle là et
finalement se casser le nez sur la sur
la révolte sociale sur la manière dont
le peuvent va recevoir les choses et
c'est aussi ce qu'il y avait fait son
originalité en 2017 et qu'il avait dit
qu'il ferait force de pédagogie qu'il
expliquerait beaucoup qu'il prendrait du
temps non seulement avec de la
concertation mais aussi avec de
l'explication sans s'affirmer sur les
objectifs depuis qu'il le fait depuis le
mois de septembre je crois que la
pédagogie on aura à peine trois semaines
pour nous la faire donc ça sera bien
trop court et pourtant sur ce type de
projet là je crois que c'est vraiment
important d'en faire ressentir la
nécessité si on veut que ça passe alors
faudra aussi surveiller évidemment
l'attitude du parti LR les républicains
écouter Gérard Larcher c'était ce matin
sur RMC
vous savez je le dis depuis longtemps
c'est une réforme indispensable qui
nécessite du courage mais cette réforme
elle est indispensable demain pour
sauver notre système de retraite
allongez la durée du travail le faire
d'une manière qui soit concerté qui
prennent en compte les carrières longue
qui prennent en compte ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler à moins de 20 ans
c'est-à-dire tout est dans l'amendement
que le Sénat depuis 2020 propose à
chaque projet de loi de financement
en tous les cas j'ai vu que
l'inspiration n'était pas très éloignée
de celle qui nous a conduit depuis trois
années à travailler autour de ça au
Sénat Rafael Legendre c'est clairement
un atout dans le dans le jeu là dans
l'équation qu'on est en train de décoder
autour de cette réforme c'est un atout
dans le jeu de du président de la
République évidemment et de toute façon
LR sera le flotteur sur lequel la
Renaissance dorénavant et non plus la
République commence pardon devra
s'appuyer s'il veut faire passer ça sera
pas simple tout au long du quinquennat
bien sûr mais sur ce texte des retraites
c'est évidemment le groupe qui fera la
différence votre ou pas quel que soit le
pardon quel que soit le
nouveau président du parti
oui quel que soit le nouveau président
du parti
il y a des lignes plus
collaboratives et constructive que
d'autres bien évidemment mais on voit
mal
erikiotique qui semble-t-il et le favori
pour cette élection
appelé à voter contre la réforme des
retraites alors que
c'est un dossier sur lequel ils ont été
partis prenantes d'abord quand la
Sarkozy avec
Eric verte avait passé sa réforme en son
temps on va on voit mal les arguments
qui pourraient être mis en avant par
Eric Ciotti pour justifier d'un non vote
de cette réforme très clairement alors
il y a une autre donnée qui est
évidemment très importante dans cette
équation c'est le rôle de la
CFDT syndicat plutôt réformiste je vous
propose un extrait du communiqué publié
ce matin après l'annonce donc
d'ouverture de de concertation on en a
choisi un passage la CFDT reste attaché
à une réforme globale du système pour
plus de justice sociale et pas un
catalogue de mesure elle réaffirme son
refus d'un report de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite à 65 ans qui
pénaliserait les travailleurs dit de
deuxième ligne qui ont contribué à
soutenir le pays pendant le covid les
femmes et les salariés qui ont commencé
à travailler tôt je propose à terme
traduit de nous rejoindre sur ce plateau
bonsoir than bon bienvenue on va voir
comment la CFDT a évolué justement dans
le temps à propos de cette réforme des
retraites
il y a eu des hauts il y a eu des bas et
pourtant tout investi bien commencé
début du premier quinquennat la CFDT
n'est pas hostile mais alors pas du tout
au premier projet de réforme des
retraites cette réforme systémique que
voulait le président de la République on
a l'impression qu'elle a été écrite par
la CFDT rappelons que depuis 2010 déjà
le syndicat réformiste et favorable à un
système universel la retraite à point du
coup c'est l'un des moyens techniques de
mettre cette réforme en oeuvre avril
2018 la CFDT s'allume
le lancement déconcertations à l'époque
avec Jean-Paul Delevoye au commissaire
aux retraites voilà ce que dit la
centrale elle est impatiente elle dit ce
n'est pas sans une forme de soulagement
que les organisations syndicales voient
enfin les discussions prendre corps mais
depuis voilà la position de la CFDT a
bien changé oui décembre 2019 c'est le
clash Edouard Philippe est encore
Premier ministre et il utilise les mots
qui fâchent ces mots c'est qu'ils
parlent de fixer un âge d'équilibre à 64
ans on a aussi entendu parler de
l'expression h pivot pour Laurent Berger
ça y est la ligne rouge est franchie le
mois de décembre 2019 va être marqué par
des grèves d'ampleur pour protester
contre la réforme des retraites un
mouvement qui va s'éteindre de lui-même
tout comme la réforme qui va être gelée
3 mois plus tard avec la pandémie de
covid mais voilà que la réforme des
retraites fait donc son retour a pendant
la campagne présidentielle et là on ne
parle plus de réforme du système mais on
parle d'un problème de financement
Emmanuel Macron parle du report de l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite à 64 à 65
et voilà la réponse de la CFDT le report
de l'âge de la retraite à 65 ans c'est
hors de question
et pas plus que nous nous réclamions de
nouvelles hausses de la durée de
cotisation hier en rentrant de ce
congrès nous n'en a réclamerons demain
ce que nous exigeons
ce que nous exigeons c'est un système de
retraite plus juste voilà c'était le
discours de clôture de Laurent Berger
lors du dernier congrès de la CFDT en
juin dernier et on le voit ce qui prime
c'est le Nini ni retraite à 65 ans ni
durcissement de la réforme Touraine
est-ce qu'on peut parler d'une forme de
radicalisation de la CFDT sur ce dossier
parce qu'il s'est joué à des choses en
interne lors de ce congrès Laurent
Berger a dû donner des gages à sa base
qui réclamait elle une position plus
dure que la direction de la centrale une
opposition très claire à toute
accélération sur la hausse de la durée
de cotisation et cela complique donc un
peu aujourd'hui à l'équation du
gouvernement la CFDT il faut le rappeler
avait fini à par signer en 2003 en 2014
les réformes des retraites et cela
n'avait pas été sans conséquence à
notamment en 2003 François Chirac était
alors secrétaire général de la CFDT il
avait déclenché une crise énorme au
syndicat en acceptant de signer et
provoquer un départ massif des adhérents
aujourd'hui alors que Laurent Berger
bien d'être réélu pour un dernier mandat
qui va certainement s'interrompre d'ici
quelques mois l'objectif est bien de ne
pas braquer sa base alors que la
centrale peine aussi à recruter de
nouveaux adhérents merci Etam pour
toutes ces explications Sylvain boulouc
c'est vrai qu'on parle souvent de la
CFDT comme d'un syndicat réformiste
est-ce que ça a changé ou est-ce que ces
ponctuellement autour de cette réforme
des retraites que finalement Laurent
Berger a peut-être un peu moins de marge
de manœuvre comment vous l'analysez la
première chose tous les toutes les
centrales syndicales sont réformistes
moi j'ai toujours été frappé de ça
localement ici il y a énormément
d’accords signés mais nationalement on a
l'impression que ça déposition et des
histoires qui sont différentes donc il y
a des il y a des visions du réformisme
qui peuvent être relativement
différentes pour ce qui est de la CFDT
le contrat moral qui avait été passé
avec Macron plus ou moins au début du
1er quinquennat était on veut bien une
réforme mais à condition que ce soit une
réforme par point enfin un changement
global de du régime des retraites à
partir vraiment c'est juste la poursuite
des précédents très forts avec
allongement du de la durée du travail de
la durée du travail oui et il recule de
la chaleur retraite la CFDT a aucun
intérêt puisque ça correspond pas à sa
philosophie à sa philosophie du travail
ou sa philosophie et ça et donc à sa
philosophie de la retraite à aucun
intérêt à prouver cette réforme alors
ils peuvent essayer de sauver les
meubles et de négocier sur quelques
points mais globalement
l'esprit de la centrale serait
enfin une signature d'un accord comme ça
serait contraire à l'esprit de la
centrale et à ce que la centrale veut
espérer mettre en oeuvre comme acteur
social répondeur mais si on refait un
peu de de de mécanique syndicale j'ai
passé le terme d'employer mais est-ce
qu'une réforme comme celle-là peut
passer sans qu'aucun syndicat de la
signe
c'est les pouvoirs législatif qui
décident après
est-ce qu'on va être dans l'équation
raffary Nesque qui était c'est pas la
rue qui gouverne c'est le gouvernement
si on est dans une situation où on est
presque à Jupiter donc la réforme des
retraites 95 vous avez plusieurs
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
défilent très régulièrement là on peut
absolument pas mais là c'est le principe
d'un mouvement social c'est je peux pas
vous dire aujourd'hui si la réforme des
retraites peut
passer en l'état ou ça ça dépendra de
des colères en sachant que vous avez
tout l'hiver dans lequel vous allez
avoir des augmentations assez
importantes des prix
on peut avoir une crise économique assez
forte et que là ça peut avoir un impact
sur la colère d'opinion un petit peu se
fixer sur cette réforme des retraite on
en parle de cette colère de l'opinion
depuis six mois depuis même avant que
l'élection présidentielle ne commence on
a vu aujourd'hui que les Français
étaient peu mobilisés je ne je ne dis
pas du tout qu'ils ne vont pas se
mobiliser mais en tout cas du côté
d'élysée ils ont fait un constat et je
pense que c'est un constat qui est
argumenté c'est à dire que ils ont fait
des sondages qu'ils ont des capteurs
dans le territoire et pour le moment ils
ne sont pas vraiment inquiets d'une
mobilisation massive et quand on voit
aussi le la fracture qu'il y a entre les
syndicats qui avant mobilisaient les
troupes et aujourd'hui les Français qui
finalement sont totalement
individualisés et n'écoutent plus
vraiment les mots d'ordre des syndicats
c'est vrai que il y a un gros point
d'interrogation sur cette colère sociale
il tape sur effectivement ce mot
lassitude et puis la difficulté ou la
plus faible capacité de mobilisation des
syndicats dans l'opinion que le cas
d'autres époque le principe d'un
mouvement social c'est que c'est pas
forcément les organisations syndicales
qui qui l'organisent réellement et ça
peut être tout à fait spontané et puis
on ne sait absolument pas qu'elles vont
être les conséquences de la guerre
nukraine et
des fermetures d'entreprise qui commence
à il a quel va être là je vous dis je ne
sais absolument pas c'est très bien de
garder cette humilité on n'a pas encore
parlé de on va terminer là-dessus nous
reste un peu moins de 5 minutes
d'Elizabeth borne uncharlen beezina et
elle est sur en ligne elle est sur une
ligne de négociation aller sur une ligne
de on se rappelle que ça a été une une
négociatrice justement quand elle était
président soit de la RATP soit de soit
de la SNCF donc elle sait faire elle
sait faire mais elle est déjà sur une
ligne de Premier ministre c'est-à-dire
qu'a priori c'est pas elle qui va
décider du tempo du fond et de ce qui va
se passer donc elle
l'aménage elle joue bien son rôle de
fusible entre l'Assemblée nationale et
le président
après c'est surtout qu'il va falloir
qu'elle associe sa majorité qu'elle soit
vraiment confortée ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose sur lequel a priori on
peut lui faire confiance puisque donc
elle a déjà négocié en temps difficile
j'ajoute quand même un point sur ce
qu'on a dit c'est que en réalité c'est
vrai qu'on se focalise un petit peu sur
les syndicats mais je crois vraiment
qu'on a vu avec l'exemple des gilets
jaunes et c'est pas uniquement en France
que c'est le cas en Espagne en Italie
etc les les révoltes sociales elles se
font maintenant de manière très
marginale des corps intermédiaires c'est
c'est plus nécessairement les les
syndicats c'est plus nécessairement les
partis politiques c'est à un moment un
ras-le-bol qui va faire que on va se
fédérer autour de d'intérêt commun etc
et c'est un petit peu le risque de cette
réforme des retraites dans une période
de crise
économique énergétique de guerre etc
c'est que tout est assez hautement
inflammable et sans concertation et sans
justement sans organisation c'est ça
peut être complètement désorganisé et
complètement imprévisible je reste sur
le quand même le ce que Elisabeth borne
avec vous Raphaël Legendre pourrait vous
souhaiter je pense elle voulait
peut-être intégrer justement vous lisez
les régimes spéciaux tout à l'heure je
pense qu'il faut terminer là-dessus
parce que c'est c'est pas neutre et ça
peut là aussi être un peu comment on
peut dire Tweety business ou une affaire
à risque quoi c'est le sujet à
surveiller dans les semaines qui
viennent les régimes spéciaux Elizabeth
borne en tant que ministre du Travail
avant d'être nommé à Matignon a commencé
à réformer ses régimes spéciaux elle l'a
fait avec la SNCF la gym question c'est
la SNCF je le rappelle RATP et EDF la
fait sans trop de problèmes à la SNCF ça
c'est plutôt bien passé en 2019-2020 et
elle voulait un paquet complet sur cette
réforme des retraites donc y compris
celle des régimes spéciaux qui va être
un point absolument
douloureux et en même temps déterminant
sur la capacité d'Emmanuel Macron à
réformer et notamment chez EDF
aujourd'hui vous avez plus de la moitié
des centrales qui sont à l'arrêt qui
sont appelés dans les semaines plus
d'une vingtaine presque une trentaine de
réacteurs sont appelés à être réactivés
dans les semaines qui viennent pour
qu'on puisse passer l'hiver au chaud
qu'il n'y ait pas de coupure
d'électricité pour les ménages pour les
entreprises et tous les agents d'EDF
vont être très fortement mobilisés pour
la réouverture donc si je vous écoute
les énerver avec une réforme rouge de de
la réforme des régimes spéciaux au
moment où ils vont être tout
particulièrement mobilisé et au moment
où l'entreprise en plus change de patron
lucrémont était officiellement désigné
aujourd'hui PDG de l'entreprise le sujet
était mis sur la table il est il fait
partie de la négociation va donc parler
du la suppression du régime spécial
d'EDF de GDF de la RATP alors avec une
clause du grand-père comme ça avait été
le cas pour la SNCF c'est-à-dire que
tous ceux qui bénéficient aujourd'hui
cette protection continueront à la voir
tous les nouveaux entrants au sein de DF
passerait sur le régime général mais ça
va être un point très sensible qui va
falloir surveiller dans les prochaines
semaines merci beaucoup merci à tous les
trois d'avoir participé à ce débat
bientôt sur sur public Sen